[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen in meine taten wird
heute habe ich endlich mal wieder einen
torten rezept für euch das rezept habe
ich allerdings schon von einer ganzen
weile gedreht da hatte ich auch gar
nicht meine kitchenaid deswegen wundert
euch nicht nur um eine alte maschine
ich mache heute die russische band heute
meine mutter schokolade isst er kennt
ihr ja bereits jetzt habe ich ja schon
vor etlichen monaten veröffentlicht und
ich habe jetzt nichts anderes gemacht
als einen leckeren schoko teig zu backen
hab dann den total gehen damit ihr
durchgeschnitten und mit der
musterschüler creme gefüllt und das wort
dann im prinzip auch schon die torte
bevor es jetzt zu dem motorola rezept
geht muss ich natürlich erst den teig
herstellen und zutaten dafür die zeige
ich euch jetzt wird den rührteig braucht
ihr vier eier
die sollten zimmertemperatur haben 160
gramm puderzucker 85 gramm öl 130 gramm
mineralwasser 130 gramm mehl 30 g
speisestärke 30 gramm packung und zwei
teelöffel backpulver das sind 10 gramm
ihr könnt an stelle des wassers auch
etwas likör oder kaffee nehmen für den
teig dann bekommt euer tag nämlich ein
ganz tolles aroma gerade kaffee nicht
schmeckt ganz groß schlägt dann nicht zu
sehr nach kaffee weil er nicht so viel
drin ist aber man bekommt einfach so
einen leichten gegner mehr aber so wie
ich wasser verwendet hat einfach eine
ganz normale schokolade oder eben auch
sehr gut schmeckt wie immer kommen jetzt
zuerst die eier in eure richtung und die
werden jetzt mit dem puderzucker
aufgeschlagen und was schön cremig ich
lass dir jetzt einmal das durchschlagen
und gibt währenddessen dann den
puderzucker dazu und es kann so etwa
fünf bis sechs minuten dauern
[Musik]
die einer creme dann schön dick ist
ihr seht hier ganz deutlich dann können
die restlichen zutaten rein das einmal
ganz kurz verrührt nicht so hoch werden
deswegen reicht auch die menge für mein
herz ich werde das jetzt in dieser
herzform backen und so werde ich den
teig jetzt bei 175 grad backen
ich denke da der teig nicht so hoch ist
weder etwa 20 minuten brauchen so sieht
der teig dann nach dem backen aus den
denke ich jetzt mit einem etwas feuchten
küchentuch ab und lass ihn einmal
komplett auskühlen
nach dem abkühlen setze ich meinen tag
auf einer kuchen platte das backpapier
ziehe ich dann einfach drunter weg indem
ich das hier so ein klappe und wegziehen
[Applaus]
den kuchen stelle ich jetzt zur seite
und wer zu lange die füllung vorbereiten
wenn ein neuer teil vollständig
abgekühlt ist könnt ihr euch um die
russische rola creme kümmern
die zutaten dafür kennt ihr bereits ich
werde es trotzdem ist auch in diesem
video erwähnen einfach damit ihr alles
jetzt hier vollständig habt und darf
jetzt seitlich einmal die zutaten und
zubereitung dafür braucht ihr nur diese
vier zutaten und zwar für ein becher
schlagsahne das sind 200 gramm 50 gramm
zucker und 200 gramm
zartbitterschokolade jetzt werden zuerst
die eier getrennt
in eiweiß und eigelb
[Musik]
die schokolade könnt ihr erst mal zur
seite stellen
jetzt werde ich mit der hälfte des
zucker verrühren und die andere hälfte
des zuckers kommt zum schnee damit man
den später besser und erheben können und
er mehr stabilität bekommt während ich
also hier jetzt das eigelb schlage und
die hälfte des zuckers mit dazu gebe
werde ich hier die eiweiße steif
schlagen und dann nach und nach die
andere hälfte des zuckers einrieseln
lassen
[Musik]
währenddessen auch noch die sahne
geschlagen und hier die eier zucker
master schönfärberisch bis sie schön
cremig da kommt jetzt die schokolade mit
dazu
die habe ich am anfang in der mikrowelle
geschmolzen auf ganz niedriger stufe
ganz vorsichtig ihr könnt es aber auch
über einem wasserbad machen auf jeden
fall ist wichtig dass sie bis dahin
abgekühlt ist
jetzt kommt die schokolade hier mit rein
ich mache das jetzt auf stufe 2 und es
sollte schon gut verrührt werden damit
die schokolade sich nicht am boden
festsetzt und dort zu haben klümpchen
wert
[Musik]
gebe ich etwas kommt der schneemasse
hier rein
so etwa ein drittel heute kann bisher
stellen einreichen und dann kam da bist
du dazu
zum schluss dann auch die sahne
unterheben
[Musik]
dann stelle ich die creme ganz kurz in
den kühlschrank und kümmere mich um den
boden
den habe ich hier nämlich auch eine
tortenplatte gesetzt und ihr seht da ist
schön hoch geworden eigentlich wollte
ich die torte nicht fühlen aber da jetzt
doch so schön hoch geworden ist werde
ich ihn jetzt einmal durchschneiden und
dann mit der mosel fülle
da lege ich ein
die springform wieder außen rum und
damit der rand nicht so verkehrt wird
nehme ich mir die kraft papierstreifen
unter dem 2
[Musik]
hat sie erzählt in dem fall weil es
besser wenn meine backform vorstellbar
wäre dann wird sie sich schön an den
teig anpacken da hat sich nämlich dann
beim backen und beim abkühlen
zusammengezogen deswegen ist ihr sohn
rand drin aber ich hoffe dass jetzt die
creme nicht zu sehr ausläuft und
deswegen lasse ich sie jetzt einfach für
eine viertel stunde im kühlschrank
stehen und dann werde ich die torte
damit befüllen
die muss ist jetzt deutlich dicker
geworden jetzt gebe ich dir einfach hier
in die mitte nun leben unterstreicht es
schön dann kommt der deckel drauf und
die restliche creme
[Musik]
einfach mal so im kühlschrank fest
welten und schaut und später wie es
aussieht
nach einer stunde im kühlschrank sie die
torte dann so aus ich versuche den
rahmen zu lösen
dann kommt es noch mal in den
kühlschrank
dann nehme ich hier noch mal eine tafel
schokolade
das geht jetzt am besten wenn ihr die
schokolade an euch abstürzt und dann mit
der messe einfach drüber geht und dann
habt ihr hier so schoko späne und die
könnte dann einfach über eure torte
geben
[Musik]
so sieht es waren bei mir auf dann fange
ich hier das backpapier entfernen und
habe dort schöne saubere torten ränder
so ständig die torte jetzt in den
kühlschrank lassen schön durch kühlen
und wir werden diese damen morgen früh
essen derzeit bereits über eine stunde
den tortenring entfernt ihr könnt dann
aber auch ganz gut über nacht im
kühlschrank stehen lassen und eben ganz
fest werden lassen und dann den ring
entfernen falls in mögliche zu den
kleineren kuchen machen wollt ist es
vielleicht besser weiter bequem aktuell
nach einer stunde noch nicht so fest ist
wie bei mir ich würde die torte
mindestens vier stunden kühl stellen vor
dem verzehr einfach damit die creme
feste konsistenz hat und nicht runter
läuft wenn man den kuchen an schneidet
ihr könnt einen kuchen natürlich
dekorieren wie ihr wollt ihr könnt auch
gekaufte schokostreusel darüber geben
oder diese show solchen ein ganz anderes
dekomaterial ich hatte jetzt leider mixa
hat deswegen der woche später verwendet
ich hoffe das konzept gefällt euch und
ihr werdet es mal ausprobieren demnächst
fertig hält mit meiner herbstaktion
starten was ich da jetzt ganz genau noch
sage ich euch dann werden sie heute ist
es wird so etwa 1 1 bis 2 wochen zeigen
vorher kommt noch ein smoothie rezept
von dessen ära im jahr macht
ballettmusik rezept genau
und dann wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen schreibt man auf jeden fall
den kommentar über eine bewertung werde
ich mich auch freuen und dann sehen wir
uns im nächsten mal wieder und bis bald
nein
[Musik]